hi my name is amy walham fechtel
and i'm going to talk to you today about
some ways that i think we can create
more inclusive
spaces in tech
so
before i got into programming
i was a professor of history and gender
studies and one of the things that i
really appreciate about good historians
and feminist scholars is that they often
start out by articulating their
structural position in relation to the
thing that they're studying or talking
about
they acknowledge that all knowledge is
partial and that perspective and lived
experience matter and so i'm gonna
follow that example i'm white
i i was raised comfortably middle class
i was educated in private schools i'm
abled cisgender and heterosexual i'm
also news flash not perfect i'm a white
woman talking about diversity and that
opens me to a number of justifiable
critiques
i will make mistakes and misstatements
please talk to me about how to do better
i'll also at points in this talk make
some generalizations about groups of 40
minutes
i do understand and stipulate that there
is no possible way that any statement
can cover all members of a group because
people are too diverse and individual
so
this is the confessionary slide this
talk is also a bit of an act of
self-defense
at times when i've been in conversations
and have pointed out that a certain
strategy like say anti-bias training has
drawbacks the follow-up question i most
often get is well okay but what should
we be doing
um and up until now my response has
really been that people know more about
what doesn't work
than what does and i became dissatisfied
with giving that answer so i went
looking and so a lot of the ideas that i
want to talk about today
are relatively new
they are they're theories they're based
on cross-disciplinary studies of what
has and hasn't worked and why with the
aim of theorizing and coming up with
some new ideas about how to more
consistently create successful diversity
inclusion and equity programs
so relatedly i'm going to cover a fair
amount of ground in this talk and i have
made a decision to trust your
intelligence ability and perhaps
patience
in that
i am not necessarily going to cover all
background material
in an attempt to make space for less
commonly discussed information so if i
do lose you i have provided a link to a
bibliography solid academic tradition
right at the end of the talk there's a
qr code uh it's organized by category
there's also it's just thrown up as a
markdown file on github also please feel
free to reach out
to me on slack twitter or via email
so the other result of talking a lot
about recent research and theory is that
i can't offer you a bunch of known
examples of people successfully
implementing these ideas in tech
communities specifically i'll give what
examples i can but they'll come from a
variety of professions and contexts as
we'll see
so amy
what are you calling for
thesis statement
i'd like to suggest some rethinking and
rebalancing along several axes that i'll
detail in the next slide and i want to
be clear that i don't see these as
binary choices i think a lot of times
people tend to think of these kinds of
things as kind of on off switches either
or choices
uh and so everything i'll be talking
about today is kind of both and it's a
question of rebalancing
an adjustment along a spectrum
so um how
i would like to argue that we get to
more equitable and inclusive spaces i'm
going to cover a few things starting
with
the dangers of the concept of technology
and how we often use it to obscure
social forces that are behind the
physical artifacts the things that we
tend to think of when we say technology
and how this affects thinking about
diversity and tech
then i want to suggest that people move
from an emphasis on openness and
individual freedom
to balancing those ideas with
consideration for civility and care in
communities
i want to suggest we make moves from
putting policies in place to thinking
hard about how to put those policies
into day-to-day practice
and i want to talk about some moves from
uh an emphasis on representation to an
emphasis on equity and i'll also suggest
some metrics that might help uh groups
think about things a little differently
and i think of these things i just put
up here on the slide is kind of a
progression they can be worked in
parallel but they also
do build on each other it's kind of a
build the plane while you're flying it
so
i want to start off with technology and
i do love this quote from heidegger the
essence of technology is by no means
anything technological
when people talk about diversity in tech
they often unthinkingly imbue this word
technology with powers it simply doesn't
have
a technology a thing
is part of a socio-technical system that
is composed yes of things but also
of people and social norms
the problem can be that the thing comes
to represent the entire system we reduce
it to the object
so the idea of technology can be
hazardous because it is subject to this
kind of reification which is what
happens when we treat something abstract
like a socio-technical system as though
it were a concrete thing like a computer
so the biggest issue with this is that
it tends to make the object seem
objective rather than a product of human
activity with all the biases that tend
to accompany that and then to make
matters more difficult we amplify the
hazardous character of the concept by
investing it with agency by using the
word technology as the subject of active
verbs so i'm going to give you an
example here
the cotton picking machine pictured here
transformed the southern agricultural
economy and set off the great migration
of black work workers to northern cities
so
the cotton picking machine is the
subject of that sentence as though it
produced
the
african diaspora into northern cities so
by treating inanimate objects machines
as
causal agents
we divert attention from the human
relations that are more directly
responsible for precipitating social
upheaval so there's always a danger in
replacing
a socio-technical system with a sort of
representing object
so when it comes to diversity in tech
specifically
um i think that diversity advocates need
to be aware of this this temptation
to focus on getting diverse people into
programming careers in the hopes that
this will eventually allow society to
tackle structural inequality like if we
can just make diverse
habits so that diverse people are making
the thing
like the thing will then be able to fix
society
um but structural inequality is baked
into the idea of technology and
socio-technical systems in the same way
it's baked into other ideas say
meritocracy
technology or again a socio-technical
system
is no more equipped
to avoid the imbalances of power that
are inherent in societies than is any
other endeavor
and so i want to talk a bit now about
what sorts of socio-technical systems i
think we have and what sorts i'd like to
suggest
people build
the slide is a private joke the head on
this guy is john locke so a
socio-technical system
i think i'd like to have is one that
focuses less on individual autonomy and
pays more attention to civility and care
so
i think that
one aspect of the culture is software
development and i've been a software
developer for not quite four years now
so i'm still kind of a toddler software
developer really
i
so but i think that one aspect of the
culture is this kind of i don't know
what else to call it other than uh kind
of a 21st century rebellious liberalism
it's dedicated to
ideas of free expression individual
liberty and autonomy it questions
institutions and configurations of power
often through reform and sometimes
through disruption
these ideals
come from and contribute ongoingly to
cultures that are unthinkingly centered
on white sis hat western male values so
what do i mean when i say unthinkingly
centered well i mean that people
struggle to see things that don't fit
into their existing paradigms first
weird example we're going to talk about
pinyon jays
so i love this example it's from pinion
j research pinion js are very social
birds and researchers wanted to study
dominance hierarchies among these birds
and so how does a biologist study
dominance hierarchies
well it turns out the common proxy for
this is to study to look for aggression
among males
so uh but they had trouble producing
fights among the males of the species
even giving them like choice tidbits of
food
so
what do you do in that case
well in the case of opinion j
researchers the answer and this is
common if you've ever read thomas kuhn's
uh
book on paradigm shifts is we're well we
just need to redefine aggression clearly
we're looking for the wrong things and
so what they did was they redefined
aggression down to being something as a
minor as just a hard glare between two
male birds and with this condition they
were in fact able to identify kind of a
weak sort of alpha
meanwhile
they describe in their notes regular
fights among the females
but these descriptions are not included
in their thinking about dominance
hierarchies because they don't fit the
paradigm they're among females not among
males and i just want to reinforce this
point
um
researchers even noted that upon the the
death of the alpha that they'd
identified
that the new alpha had coincidentally
recently mated with a high status female
so what is the point here the point is
that they simply these researchers could
not see
a hierarchy that was characterized by
female aggression all of us have these
spots of blindness where things don't
fit the way
that
we currently feel like the world works
so i think the same sorts of phenomena
can manifest in how tech communities
think about having debates around
what makes good
software there's a value on free
expression and being able to say exactly
what you think programmers have lots of
axioms it seems to me
about
how to have conversations around making
good software so how many of you have
ever found yourself in a conversation
that has looked something
like this this is the right way to do it
only an idiot would use mongodb all of
our users would kill for that feature we
absolutely should use go rust closure
i'm going to stick with the functional
languages and the popular ones at this
conference here
because i don't want
to be murdered
this definitely needs to be
a microservice a monolith a microlift
service mesh distributed cloud native
reactive blockchain infrastructure is
code
blue
a pickle
so
thank you i shall mock you again
um
i think a lot of developers see these
conversations as pretty normal just like
researchers considered it normal to look
for dominance hierarchies among males of
the species
and i think
open communities can be particularly
susceptible where they value free
expression
to this sort of i don't know what to
call it is such an absolute discursive
style this is the way things are
and i think this creates a few problems
one is that the ethic of freedom
prevents
an effective response to such behavior
um because i'm going to back that up for
a second
because
it means that if all expression is
allowable there's no reasonable response
if that's your value system and then
when asked to moderate it people
sometimes appeal to free expression they
argue that they shouldn't have to modify
their discourse because the internet is
a socially leveling force it's a
perfectly level liberal sphere it's full
of freedom and it supersedes how social
identities are lived offline
so
problem being that this relies on an
assumption
that the internet is separate from the
real world
but most of us especially in this
profession live a significant portion of
our lives online
the internet does not change power
dynamics or discursive styles we bring
the real world with us
and thinking that the internet does
change those things is taking how a
group thinks the world should work
and mistaking it for how the world does
work
when it comes to discussions of
diversity appeals to freedom and
openness can be used to rationalize
the lack of diversity as a matter of
personal preference and choice
and another example of this kind of
pinyon j dynamic
underrepresented people's description of
this way of speaking as harmful tends to
provoke
an understandably dismayed response from
men
this suggests that some women and
minorities are alienated by behaviors
that are positively valued by men and so
put another way the paradigms of some
underrepresented people
define as harmful
a behavior that the dominant
unconsidered paradigm defines as
downright positive natural
and normal
hence the dismayed response
one strategy i think can tilt the
balance here towards civility and care
is codes of conduct and other clearly
articulated standards of behavior
because they set a standard for the
acceptable tone and content of
communication
they help move a group from an emphasis
on technical expertise as the most
important thing
to a broader emphasis on valuing work
that supports the project including but
not limited to things like documentation
and evangelism
it also decreases the likelihood that
contributions from minority groups will
be judged by different standards than
those of cis white western men
and having a code of conduct lets
underrepresented folks assess the
community's commitment to diversity and
whether or not that there are good
policies in place to address problems
for communities that do have codes of
conduct or seeking to implement one
there's an additional set of challenges
that often arises
how does a community define exactly what
it means by diversity
scholars have suggested that the word
diversity can be vague and slippery they
often talk about it as
mobile the meaning moves depending on
your context
it's a super commonly used term and it
can be
very broad
such that what's being named is diverse
sort of the thing that you're describing
is diverse becomes more important
or becomes less significant than just
naming it diverse so this these are
things like word diverse company
right or we're a diverse community
what exactly does that mean
really like what is the content behind
the word diversity
the who of diversity and definitions
also
matters i've seen arguments in tech that
diversity often defaults to women and
implicitly to white women
in other american settings diversity can
be read as for referring first and
foremost to racial diversity and at its
broadest the term can come to mean any
difference between two individuals be it
physical ideological or social
and this vagueness can result in
diversity becoming disconnected
and i think this is a real danger from
any analysis of power dynamics and that
renders it impossible for the idea of
diversity to do any
work to help reshape structural
inequality in tech
and to be clear i'm not advocating for a
definition i'm not going to present you
with a definition i'm suggesting it's
important to know what any given
community means when they say diversity
everyone doesn't have to have the same
definition everybody does need to know
what they're aiming at
so
then
communities often face additional
challenges
when you write a code of conduct or
another document the next step is to try
and get it to be live practice because a
big part of diversity work currently is
getting commitments written into
documents but then the weird this weird
thing happens where documents especially
if definitions are vague can kind of
become substitutes for actually doing
the thing
so it becomes we have a diversity policy
we're a diverse organization
even when day-to-day practice
remains problematic
in fact pro-diversity structures can
lead majority group members
to presume organizational fairness and
dismiss evidence of discrimination even
to the point where courts have accepted
the president the presence of a
diversity policy as evidence that
discrimination have not has cannot have
occurred
so once there's a document
people who continue to point out the
problem can then themselves come to be
perceived as the problem
um because the document is supposed to
solve the problem so you get things like
well what do you mean we're a diverse
organization we hold our policy
so this dynamic i think demands that we
begin to think about how to move from
documents and policies to ensuring that
those are lived out in practice i think
strong definitions can help
i think metrics can also help
and here i want to touch on two related
moves that i think communities can make
the first is to think hard about whether
representation numbers of people is
enough
and consider developing metrics that
examine various dimensions of equity to
complement measuring representation and
i'll suggest some ways to do this
the second is to consider whether
efficiency is the right framing for
thinking about diversity and i want to
suggest something i'll call recursivity
because i love to make up words that
might be a better indicator of
environments that foster equity and
justice
so amazon
really does me a solid in this respect
this is a global workforce data
and so the first sentence on the page
right
representation matters this is a common
focus in corporate diversity programs
right now
so
um and then as you begin to move down
the page
this doesn't look too bad global
workforce data so the gender splits
reasonably even and there seems to be a
reasonable ethnic distribution
field and customer support the lowest
levels in amazon look about the same
as their global workforce and then as
you begin to move down the page it
rapidly becomes more male
and more white
so
representational diversity statistics
often hide
things like this and the focus here is
on numbers of people
do numbers of people matter absolutely
they do are they all that matters no
having people like getting people in the
door is a necessary but it is not a
sufficient condition for a fully
inclusive environment
so i think the key insight here for me
is remembering that increased
representation does not always mean
increased power and i think the amazon
statistics are actually a great
representation
of that
a seat at the table doesn't necessarily
mean a voice so
just programming or owning an iphone
doesn't give you power to shape apple's
product line or how they choose to
organize a business
and so focusing on representation
especially when it is paired with a
loose definition of diversity i'd argue
cannot fully address the scary concepts
like power inequality
justice requires not only recognition
not only representation
but redistribution
and so representational diversity
efforts do provide the opportunity for
inclusion but they often fall short
so and i'll talk a little bit more about
uh some ways that
i'd like to suggest might help fix that
here in a minute but i wanted to talk
about two kind of metrics related moves
and the second is moving from efficiency
to recursivity so what i mean when i
talk about efficiency
efficiency is a concept that is really
it pays attention to maximizing
um a single desired output
so metrics that measure efficiency look
at the ratio of the value of inputs to
outputs and you know hopefully the
outputs are more than the inputs in a
capitalist system that's usually
monetary inputs um or some proxy like
level of effort right we've all put that
on jira cards at some point
um for diversity advocates though this
means that it's often most effective to
frame their arguments in terms of
efficiency if you input diversity the
output is measurable in greater um
greater profit and products that appeal
to more people this is often referred to
as a market logic for diversity
simple right
thing is a lot of businesses have tried
these sorts of efficient solutions for
diversity and especially in the tech
space they've often struggled to move
numbers much
so
my alternative recursivity this measures
things based on how well value is
effectively circulated from the bottom
up in local communities the term is
inspired by the concept of recursion and
programming it is meant to evoke the
idea of a thing that uses its outputs as
inputs but it isn't meant to hew like
strictly to the the definition of
recursion in in programming
mostly just because you know i'm a
former academic and they like to make up
words and you know i think you put it on
the end of anything it makes you sound
smart and innovative so swinging for the
fences here
so
recursivity pays attention not only to
like the process of production but also
to social reproduction and that means
all
of the inputs that it takes to keep a
production cycle going so a common
example of this uh would be like if
you've ever read any like marxist
feminists they talk about social
reproduction in terms of the
reproduction of the worker and so if you
want someone to work in a factory
someone has to feed clothe and raise the
next generation
and that is an externality
and so that's what people mean when they
say reproduction the ability to fully
keep that cycle going and so
i want to give you another example here
from a 2013 social justice and peace
conference an engineer described a
labor-intensive recycling program in sri
lanka where different materials were
being handled by different companies and
all in different trucks and she was
asked in the q a
whether there been any attempts to
centralize the process to make it more
efficient and her answer focused on the
number of people employed and the
simplicity
of the process and she argued that that
was every bit as important as the amount
of material being recycled
and so i think this really reveals a
tension between resource efficiency and
social benefit and this is what
recursivity is about it's about
supporting an ecology
of mutually reinforcing positive social
outcomes even at the cost of one or
several constituent factors in the
system not reaching their maximum
theoretical potential
so metrics focused on recursivity might
measure something like sustainability or
how well outputs are used as inputs or
how well a system meets an intended
balance of a set of objectives
so i want to turn now to talking about
things
that i hope we can do in diversity
spaces that will help support this
um but i need a couple more sort of like
supporting concepts before we can get
there
the first of which is recursive depth i
figured this ought to be an easy one to
put across to a programming audience
so a recursively deep system is one that
is just made up of a whole bunch of
nested
loops
so a recursively deep system seeks out
loops that connect inputs to outputs and
nest them together
these
recursively deep systems are inherently
local
recursivity doesn't necessarily scale to
use a programming term in the same way
that efficiency might and so i think the
biggest implication of this is diversity
programs are
i'd argue ought to be
bespoke
local
the there's a real difficulty with kind
of looking at what large companies in
any given industry are doing and trying
to sort of copy paste it
uh into everybody's situation and i i
question whether that works or works
well
these systems tend towards more
democratic control of socio-technical
environments the people who are affected
by decisions have a say in them
and they foster socially just ways of
living because they create these thick
webs of social connections
so these kinds of
structures and organizations help to
make space for generative interactions
and generative justice so more terms yay
so generative interaction
is this idea that you can have
interactions that
these interactions help to challenge
guiding assumptions in an organizational
culture they lead to reconsidering
practices that up until this point have
been kind of taken for granted
they have depth they occur in a web of
social connections and then if you can
get this cycle of generative
interactions going um eventually
hopefully what you move towards is
generative justice and this occurs in
systems where value circulates in really
meaningful collaborative ways within
groups right so you get these little
local
systems that work well for the people
that are directly involved in them
so i'm just gonna
like i used to do this with my
undergrads don't panic
i know it's a big graph we're going to
go through it
so
um
i'd ask you to
breathe stay with me
so uh
if you want to take away from this it's
going to be the uh six things that are
in the top box there that says
organizationally structured generative
interaction practices because i think
these are um if if organizations and
groups implement these six things it
makes space for generative interactions
and so what we hope is that people
uh who um
that people will experience
the following
so i'm gonna make life a little easier
focus attention
people should experience pursuing an
important organizational purpose that's
supported by leaders and shared among
members and preferably that purpose
weirdly will be something other than
diversity why well because that frame
the framing of something other than
diversity an important organizational
goal
is perceived as improving uh
interpersonal oper or personal
opportunities for everyone in the
organization including white men and so
one of the things that this does is it
tends to limit backlash
which can often be a problem with more
traditional diversity programs i had a
whole section on what not to do i had to
cut it out
to fit this into 40 minutes so we're
just going to talk about what to do
so uh secondly on this list
people should experience mixing
repeatedly using intentional community
building activities that enable
interaction across diversity because
even when you put people in a small
group they still tend to self-segregate
and hang out with people who are like
them
um and so part of creating effective
diversity structures is finding ways to
overcome that
self-segregation and also communication
anxiety uh the tendency that people have
to be like really nervous and anxious
when talking to people who are not like
them
so um if
you if organizations are set up in ways
that allow for those first two things
hopefully the next three we kind of get
as a group
for actually three steps four things
so uh
people should experience
an ability to have
repeated interaction opportunities at
high frequency and over an extended time
i feel like the explanation for this one
is pretty simple
people need practice
in order to develop better intercultural
communication skills and also to get
over discomfort of the sort that i just
talked about a second ago
giving uh also the next thing they
should experience is giving diverse
members uh equal standing and everybody
should feel like they have insider
status in contributing to the success of
the group this helps with a sense of
common in-group identity
and
lets people
transcend
while still utilizing
and recognizing differences among
members and i think this is really
important and easy to miss the object
here is not to erase difference it's to
learn to appreciate
and use it
erasing it's a fool's errand in my
opinion we can talk about that after
so um weirdly what i want to talk about
here is kind of like a community
decision making
and my example is going to be drawn from
economist studies of common pool
resource management we're going to talk
about maine lobster fishermen because
that is what you need 33 minutes into a
talk
so
uh maine lobster fishermen have local
councils that manage their their
fisheries and those councils are they're
made up of the fishermen they are
they enforce rules and norms they're
local
and they're flexible rules change over
time depending on conditions
so for example a lot of these councils
have rules about poaching on another
fisherman's area so the first time that
happens you might just tie a colorful
bit of rope on your trap kind of like i
see what you did there
so second offense might well get you a
home visit please stop doing that and
then the consequences tend to escalate
from there
up to and including things like
putting holes in your boat
so
this sort and these are agreed upon
rules by the community right so
and this sort of community norm setting
with graduated sanctions i think is a
model to consider for policies like
codes of conduct the point is not to
drive people out of a group it's to make
an environment where everyone can thrive
but that has strong consequences for
continuing harm to community resources
or relationships
so
people should also experience
collaboration and member interdependence
and i love the analogy here of mixed-use
city neighborhoods because i think they
kind of resemble cross-functional teams
they're vibrant for a number of reasons
so if anybody lives in a place like this
like people come to shop
eat sit on the porch watch other people
and it that provides eyes on the street
so the neighborhood is busy and it's
safe there is this acquaintanceship of
the street right it's not that you know
everybody in the neighborhood well or
anything like that but um you know
you'll watch somebody's bike while they
run into the deli
right so or
i loan somebody five bucks or your
neighbor down the street will keep a key
for a house guest that's coming in while
you're out of town
and these are all examples of what it
can look like to live in a place that
has a thick web of social connections
they don't have to be close
friendships
um but decent acquaintanceships i know
you i understand you you're part of my
people
um
and in this in the case of a city
neighborhood they're created by the
design of the space but i'd argue it's
also possible to create these kinds of
spaces in organizations
the last one i don't have a great
example for but people also if you get
all these other things should begin to
feel a greater sense of interpersonal
comfort and self-efficacy that's going
to increase our big bubble over there
willingness and ability to engage and as
long as that's high
then we get to move to inclusion we get
adaptive contact and generative
interactions in a loop
there's my recursivity
so you get these recursive effects
between adaptive contact willingness to
engage and those are critically
important
because frequent positive interactions
leads to greater comfort
that helps overcome anxieties
communication apprehension it dampens
people's exclusionary tendencies and
feeds back into even more
increased willingness to engage with
those interactions eventually becoming
generative involving prejudice reduction
and contact that's developmental rather
than superficial for the individuals
that are involved now the great thing
about this is that research suggests
that people who develop intercultural
communication skills also
tend to have more nuanced understanding
of problems
they're more likely to engage in
perspective taking or empathy and
they're often more creative thinkers and
these are all things that i think all of
us in tech strive for
so yeah i know i've thrown a lot at you
so i wanted to give you a bit of a
summary so here come the takeaways um
back to my slide on how i think we get
to more equitable
socio-technical systems
simply getting more diverse people into
tech
is unlikely to create a just and
equitable system because tech is just a
system it has no special qualities in
this regard we're in the same boat as
everyone else figuring out this problem
think hard about your assumptions and
paradigms and how they might obscure
others perspectives
and i think codes of conduct here are a
good step towards codifying what a
community means by inclusion what
constitutes civility good norms like the
lobster fishermen
be clear about your community's
definition of diversity and about
consequences for policy violations
and this is important remain open to
critique about whether people perceive
the policy to be working on the ground
less the people who continue to tell you
you still have problems become the
problem themselves and end up driven out
of your organization
consider measuring recursivity in
addition to or in place of efficiency
so move from thinking about
representation to thinking about equity
and
try to create systems that have
recursive depth and favor generative
justice
and i think
all of this eventually helps bend
systems towards generative justice where
recursivity becomes a characteristic
that just built into the system at
different levels
it favors recursive depth that leads to
generative interactions and ultimately
generative justice and i do think that
open source is an excellent space for
moving towards this kind of recursive
depth because it's as much a set of
social relationships as it is code it's
a collective project
it has a tradition of standing outside
the normal way of doing things
code it turns out is an excellent medium
for recursivity it's very good using its
own outputs as inputs and it turns out
using code doesn't make any less code
for anybody else
so
codes of conduct i think suggest that
open source communities are quite
capable of approaching inclusive
interactions and decision making in
really thoughtful intentional ways
what i hope is that this will give tech
communities both representation and a
better chance at equity and shifting
power balances
as well as the ability to tolerate
creative tension that is inherent in all
the differences between people and be
able to leverage that for greater
innovation
so i promised you a bibliography
so here's the link to it because there's
more than i could possibly throw up on a
slide
thank you for your time
i'll be here for questions
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you